a lot of people out there think that
Andy Richter is a nice easygoing guy and
I want to tell you he really is yeah I'd
like to think so yeah you are but I just
wanted to point out there's another
layer of Andy a layer where he really
wants people to think he's a guy who
cares passionately about American
culture I care that people think I care
yes that's a big thing for Andy yeah so
Andy wanted to take a moment to address
some of the things that everyone is
talking about are you ready Andy I'm
ready Conan Richter pretends to care
deeply about
they say Khloe Kardashian's new baby
girl has her own Instagram with a
hundred and forty four thousand
followers you go baby true that Avengers
movie made so much money this weekend
good for Marvel and Disney the Mets are
off to their best start in franchise
history woot
I can't get enough of people posting
their old headshots online that new
Cobra Kai series with Ralph Macchio may
just get me to try YouTube read it might
keep tweeting your truth Kanye but most
of all Conan has his annual checkup
tomorrow and I hope the doctor tells him
he's gonna live a really long time
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
you